قلب موسكو واهم رموزها يتعرض لهجوم
بمسيرتين تقول موسكو انهما اوكرانيا هي
ضربه ترى اوساط في داخل روسيا وخارجها
انها معنويه اكثر منها عسكريه ضربه كسرت
هيبه موسكو المعروفه بانها من اكثر
المناطق المحصنه عسكريا في البلاد تضع
موسكو الحادثه في خانه العمليات الارهابيه
وتقول انها محاوله باغتيال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي لم يكن في المكان
لحظه وقوع الحادث
فور الهجوم شكل من اشكال الحرب النفسيه
والاعلاميه الدعائيه هدفها اظهار عدم
فعاليه منظومه العسكريه الروسيه في صد
الهجمات الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا لا تستطيع
تحقيق نجاحات عسكريه على الارض وحتى
الاعلام الغربي بات يشكك في امكاناتها
صعيد جديد وخ للملف الاوكراني بحسب
مراقبين الكرملين يتواعد بالرد في المكان
والزمان المناسبين مسؤولون الروس يعتبرون
ما حدث هجوما مباشرا يستهدف الرئيس الروسي
ما يستدعي تصفيه القياده الاوكرانيه حسب
تعبيرهم فيما ذهب نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي
الى ابعد من ذلك ليوشيرا الى ان الامر كما
كان في عهد هتلر لم يعد بحاجه الى توقيع
زيلينسكي على وثيقه الاستسلام
حدث ترافق مع زياده وتيره استهداف المنشات
الروسيه من قبل الجانب الاوكراني في
المناطق الحدوديه واعلان اعتقال شبكه
عملاء تابعه للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه في
القرن وضلوع شخصيه رفيعه في مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني في تنظيم اعمال ارهابيه في
روسيا والتخطيط لاغتيال مسؤولين الروس كل
ذلك يهدد بانتقال المواجهه في اوكرانيا
الى مستوى اخر وقد يشكل حجه بحسب العديد
من المراقبين لذهاب روسيا الى ابعد مما
يسمى العمليه العسكريه هي قنبله رمزيه
فجرت قنبله بلغت الكرملين قلب موسكو
السياسيه والشعبي بانتظار شكل الرد الروسي
وحجمه على هذه الضربه المعنويه غير
المسبوقه في تاريخ روسيا راني دريدي
الجزيره موسكو